欢迎回到
FP 101 函数式程序设计
今天讨论的是类型（type）与类（class）
作为开发者 我们经常熬夜 常常过于专注以致于忘了时间
因此应当特别注意饮食
确保吃好喝好
在这个营养金字塔中
食物被分成了不同类别 比如面包 米饭 意大利面
属于碳水化合物类
其他的还有蛋白质 水果和蔬菜等
所有的食物根据某种共同的属性被分成了不同的组
可以根据这些分组说 食物是有类型的
这就是本节课要讲的 如何将代码中 具有相似属性的值（而非食物）分成不同类别
什么是类型
类型仅仅是一组有关联的值的名字
类似于食物的类型 就是一组有关联的食物集合的名字而已
编程中 类型就是一组相互关联的且有共同属性的值的集合名字
比如 Haskell 中 Bool 类型就由两个值组成 False 和 True
严格来讲 Haskell 中还有第三个值 Bottom 代表 Bool 类型的非中止计算
但本课程中仅讲基础内容
因此会忽略 Bottom 这样的复杂的特性
目前将 Bool 当作 True 和 False 两个布尔值的集合的名字
类型错误指 调用函数时 使用了意料之外的类型 看下面的例子
如果将 1 加到 False 上 当然不会成功 因为左侧是数字 右侧是布尔值
没办法将一个数字加到一个布尔值上
回到饮食的例子上
某种饮食方式可能不允许将肉和奶制品混合到一起 这就是食物中的类型错误
编程中也有类似的类型错误
静态类型的目标是让编译器提前发现类型错误 也就是在运行之前
动态类型语言中 类型错误在运行时中发现 也就是布尔值与数字实际相加时
无类型语言中 仅仅取出两个值的表示形式并试图相加
Haskell 中表达类型的语法是两个英文冒号加类型
比如对表达式 e 的求值 返回值是 t 类型的话 就写 e :: t
不同语言中语法不同 比如 Visual Basic 中写 e as t 而在 Java 中写 t e
但那仅仅是语法不同 重要的是语义 也就是表达式 e 具有类型 t
每一个语法良构的表达式都有一个类型
在编译时 这个类型被编译器用一种称为 类型推断 的过程计算出来
记得第一讲中提到了 ML 它是第一个支持类型推断的语言
Haskell 中的类型错误在编译时发现 大多数编程语言也在编译时
目前关于是用静态类型还是动态类型 还是可选类型 有不同的观点
就我个人而言 更喜欢静态
我很懒 因此希望编译器提前帮我发现类型错误
之前的课程中讲了 GHC 的使用方法 其中有一个特殊的指令 :type
可以让 GHC 帮你推断表达式的类型 并告诉你
比如输入 not False GHC 会计算 not False 的结果是 True
也可以问 not False 的类型是什么
此时不会对表达式求值 仅仅会计算类型 not False 的类型是 Bool
可以看到 not False 的值是 True 类型是 Bool 因此是一致的
GHC 做的不错 如果 not False 的类型是整数 但值是 True 就太奇怪了 这被称为类型可靠（或类型健全）
意思是编译器计算出来的类型与运行时求出来的值相一致
Haskell 和大多数编程语言中都有一些基本类型
也就是内置于编程语言中的类型
Haskell 有以下这些
我们已经看到了 Bool 类型 包含布尔值 True 和 False 还有字符类型
Char 是表示字符的值的集合的名字
Char 中包含 a b c 等等字母 还有所有的 Unicode 字符 此外还有表示字符串的 String 类型
也就是一串字符 之后我们会看到 在 Haskell 中
字符串仅仅是字符的列表
你可以认为 String 并非 Haskell 基本类型 因为它是用另外两个基本类型定义的 也就是列表和字符
Haskell 有个特别的地方 Python 中也有类似
即语言中既有 Int 类型 也有 Integer 类型
Ints 是定点整数 32 位或 64 位整数
而 Integer 是任意精度的整数
用 Integer 类型可以计算 500 的阶乘 虽然会用很长时间
但不会像用 Int 一样发生溢出 当然还有 Float 类型表示浮点数
当讲到字符时 我提到了字符串类型 String 仅仅是字符的列表  列表类型是我们在 Haskell 中遇到的第一个泛型类型 或称为多态类型
列表就是相同类型元素的序列
第一个例子是三个布尔值的列表 False True False
可以看到类型记号 冒号冒号 后面的类型是 Bool 的列表 Haskell 的一个很好的特性是
这里左侧值的语法 看起来和右面的类型的语法十分相似
我们用方括号表示值的列表 也用同样的方括号表示类型 因此 [False, True, False] 类型是 [Bool]
第二个例子是 a b c d 的列表 其类型是字符类型的列表
和字符串的类型一样
一般而言 [t] 表示 t 类型元素组成的列表类型
注意列表的类型中没有其长度信息
列表 False True 的类型是 [Bool]
如果值是 False True False 类型也是 [Bool]
元素可以是任意类型 只要所有元素类型都相同即可
最后一个例子类型有些复杂
是一个字符列表的列表 也就是这里写的
字符列表的列表 它的值是两个字符列表
列表只要求元素类型相同 但长度不受限制
这和元组（tuple）不同
元组中类型包括了长度信息 但值的类型可以不同
第一个例子是两个布尔值的元组 True 和 False
类型是 (Bool, Bool)
这不是列表 假如是列表 类型就应该是 [Bool]
但这里是两个布尔值的元组 True 和 False 类型是 (Bool, Bool)
第二个例子的类型是 (Bool, Char, Bool)
可以看到包含了三个值
第一个是布尔值 第二个是单个字符 第三个又是布尔值
这也在类型中反映出来了
一般地 如果元组类型是 (t1, ... , tn) 其值是一个值的元组且对应位置上的类型是 t1 到 tn
元组的类型包含了大小 (True, False) 和 (False, True) 的类型是 (Bool, Bool) 可以看到类型反映了长度
第二个例子中有三个布尔值 因此类型也是三个布尔类型
值的类型不受限制 因此可以混合搭配
这个元组包含一个字符 第二个值是一个由布尔值和字符组成的元组
最后一个例子是一个元组
第一个值是布尔值 之后是字符列表
这里是布尔值 True
接下来是 a b 字符的列表 可以看到类型是 (Bool, [Char])
关于类型的第一部分到此结束
接下来要讲函数 我们学的是函数式程序设计 因此函数很重要
我们将仔细讨论函数 谢谢
休息之后再见